運転
席あれええええええしてねえってねめてん
のかこのめてねえなんだよ
お前こんにちははじめ社長です僕今東京駅
に来てるんですけれども皆さんは新幹線と
いう乗り物をご存知でしょうかまさにここ
今東京駅の新幹線乗り場なんですけれども
新幹線それはみんなの希望をつぐ希望の
箱舟電車はかに早い公共交通期間日本の
いろんな場所に通ってるんですけれども
すごい速さで移動してくれるので僕もよく
静岡から東京に行く時とかも使ってます
そんな新幹線なんですけどもなんか俺新
幹線東京駅で待ってた時にこの車両は乗れ
ませんっていう新幹線が通った時があって
これ何だろうと思ってで色々調べたりした
んですけれどもなんか新
幹線貸し切れるらしいんですよ誰が
貸し切るんだろうすごい大人数の修学旅行
生とかかな新幹線が貸しれるという情報私
聞きまして
今回新幹線貸し切りまし
てこれですこの11時18分の新幹線
貸し切りまし
[音楽]
たいやできるんだできるんだってこと
ちょっとびっくりしてるんですけれども
新幹線貸し切りました
[音楽]
私あこんにちは貸し切ったら何できるん
だろう他のお客さんがいないので迷惑と
いうものは考えなくて大丈夫ですどうなん
だろう貸切ったらどんな感じになるとかも
分かんないんですけどもとりあえず今新
幹線貸し切ってもうすぐ来るので東京駅で
新幹線に乗ってちょっと大阪新大阪駅
ぐらいまで貸し切っていきたいと思います
過去最高の新幹線の旅お見せしましょうで
は
行こうもうすぐえ新幹線が来ますの普通に
お客さんがたくさんいらっしゃるのでです
ねもうすぐ来ると思い
[音楽]
ます
まし
発ましたこれ貸し切りますはいというけで
到着しました今分中ですね終わったら入れ
ますで大丈夫ですすげえこれ俺のかこれ俺
のっすよねそうですえどうしよういだっ他
のお客さんいないってこと
でしょえ車検でもいいってことですか
ちょっと楽しみだなもうすぐ多分入れる
ようになると思います見てください指定席
リザーブド予約してありますって書いて
あります誰が予約したんでしょうねえこ
乗っちゃて大丈夫
です大丈夫ですか乗っちゃってあ開きまし
た
さ行きましょう俺の新幹線
です失礼し
[音楽]
ますこれ全部です
かやば
すぎる失礼し
ます来たこれ他のお客さんがいないって
ことは何してもいいってことですよ
ね
あ
走ってもいいってことですよ
[拍手]
これこれも音なしすごいなおいこれ一応
倒し放題ってことです
かえこれ全部倒していいのいやしないです
けどいやすごいよこれが新幹線貸し切りの
力かどこ座ろうかなえじゃあもうなんか
こうやってこれこれもいいってことですか
こういう全然オッケですこうやって新大阪
行っちゃってもいいんですかあり
ですやばえじゃあのこうやって新用さ行っ
てもいいんですかもちろんオッケーです
たまに車掌さん取るからその時だけ
ちょっと避けますばいぞやりたりほやり
たり放題
[音楽]
や
1人遊びしましょうこれどうする何して
遊ぶスライディングとかしていってこと
です
[音楽]
これ30歳こんなことできないから
なかなかここだけ切り抜かれそうっすね
確かにめちゃくちゃ悪いやつみたいどこ
まで何していいかわかんないけど絶対物は
壊しちゃダメなんだよで牡蠣も危ないから
ダメなのででちょっとできる範囲で遊ぼう
と思いますとキャッチボールしようじゃ
キャッチボールしたいと思いますこれまず
炎上するぞやばい緊張する行き
ますまずはねまずはさすがにはいはいはい
はい
わ
怖えたいきます
はいうむいこれ行き
ますどっか行っちゃっ
た本気で投げてやるぜ行くよ
はいあ惜しい
惜しい普通の場所でやった方がいいですね
はじめさん隣の車両も行きましょう隣の
車両はい1秒しか貸し切ってませんそう
だったんですね全車両も貸し切れたっぽい
んですけどもあのそのあの金額もすごいの
と1人しかいないから1車両って絶対
足りるので1車両だけにしておきましたで
もね本当にあの金額次第では全車両
貸し切ることもできるらしいのででもそれ
は大人数の時かな1人の時は1車両でいい
と思います
わあいい景色だねいい景色
だいやでもやっぱり新幹線といえば何
食べる駅弁駅弁でしょ
貸し切りなのでもう駅弁とかじゃなくて
もっとなんか食べれないかなと思いまして
貸し切りだからなんかね牡蠣はダメなのよ
危ないから危ないのをそのなんか焼肉とか
やろうと思ったんですけどやっぱ牡蠣は
ダメらしいのでえ今回回転寿準備しまし
たやばくない新幹線の中で活発さんですよ
今日よろしくお願いしますよろしよしお
願い
しありがとうございますよろしくお願いし
ます新幹線でお寿司出されたことあります
初めてです初めてです
かやばい目ささん揺れてる早速いただき
ますいただきますどうぞいただき
ます
うま新幹線で食うが一番
うまいこうやって回転主も新幹線で食べる
ことができますうま
いくらいただいていいですかどうぞどうぞ
いただきますもう手で行っちゃいますから
けいきます
はいうまい最高
ゴ勢上げ放題すね
ち多分相対速度世界で一番早い変てです新
幹線結構揺れると思うんですけどそれでも
ちゃんと安定しますね安定しますね初めて
やりましたけど安定してましたこぼれる気
がしなくて最高だ
すすこれから新幹線乗る時は毎回貸し
切ろうちょゲームしてるんです
けどなんかなせっかく貸し切りしてるん
だったら大画面でやりたいなディスプレー
とか置いていいんかな新幹線バーンて見
たいねちょっとやってみたいよねという
わけでディスプレイとスイッチのドッも
持ってきたのでょ大画面スイッチやっ
ちゃおうと思いますじゃあ新幹線の中で
スイッチをディスプレイで遊びたいと思い
ます行く
ぜはめさんそこ通路ですあ通路かえでも
貸し切りだからいいよ
ね新幹線の通路でゲームするやつはいない
よ悪いことしてる気持ちに
なる
はいというわけでせっかく貸し切りなので
ちょっとドッキリしたいと思います水着
美女に来ていただきましたよろしくお願い
しますお願いし
ます新幹線って水着よあのいきなり水着だ
とさすがに変なのでちょっと私服で待って
ていただいてターゲット入ってきたら2人
ともターゲットの両隣の席に座ってえっと
その脱いでいただけると思はいわかりまし
たよろしくお願いします次の駅で
ターゲットが乗ってくるので
もし新幹線にいて両隣に美女が来て脱い
だらどういう反応するのか見ていき
[音楽]
ましょう
た
[音楽]
よ
た
[音楽]
あ大お疲れ疲れお疲れ
大なんかすごいいい指定席取ってるね
ね
えまだ行っていいあまだ出新幹線はい
貸し切りまし
た規模がでけえよ規模がでけえ何しても
いいって聞いたんでちょっと両隣なりが
水着美女だったらなるなるほどなかでき
ないんで普
はいどうですたか君はいありがとうござい
ますはいというわけで次の駅でまた1人
ターゲットがこの新幹線に乗ってくるので
次はこんなことしてみたいと思います
こちら新幹線のこの通路に人が倒れてい
たらどういう反応するのかちょっと見てみ
たいと思います俺こういうこと遭遇した
ことなくて新幹線で新幹線いろんな人が
乗ってます何が起きるか分からない人が
倒れているとターゲットはどういう反応
するのかちょっと見てみたいと思います
よろしくお願いしますお願
[音楽]
ます
この電車は
[音楽]
ご
あ
[音楽]
うわやだこんな
生活
すそう
[音楽]
つおさお疲れお疲れおどうどうしどうした
なんか泣いてますけどなんて言ってるか
わかんなかった泣いてるのか泣いて
るっぽいす会社に行きたく
ない会社に行きたくないまあまあはいそう
いう日もあるよなはいというわけでサさん
はい新幹線貸し切ってます
ヤッホーガチガチですすごあありがとう
ございますありがとうございはい
ありがとうございますえ会社が嫌すぎて新
幹線で自暴時期になった人だこんな全車両
をいや全車両やりたかったんだけどはい
さすがにいややろうと思やるけどはいいや
でもよく考えたら1車両で良くねって思っ
た確かにもう十分えそうなのよ間違
きだよ運転席と貸切できないですか運転
席あれえ
え大丈夫
か大丈夫大丈夫か大丈夫か大丈夫待って
怖い無理無理あこれガチなん
ですねなんかさっきは明る明るかったから
さ見えないあう気持ち
悪すいませ
んす
びっくりしたガチで見えなかったはいと
いうわけで次の駅でもう1人乗るんです
けれども次の実験は
こちらはい2人男性を準備しました今から
この2人にはよくあると思うんですけども
新幹線のこのぶつかると思うんです足
たまにガンてこれがサラリーマンの方が
やっちゃってえこのお兄さんが怒って喧嘩
が始まります他人の人と同じ場所にいるの
で何かしらトラブルが起きるかもしれませ
んそんな時ターゲットはどう行動するのか
ちょっと検証してみたいと思いますでお
2人よろしくお願いします願し
[音楽]
ます
当たんだ
けど当たっては当たってんだよおしくし
とけ
ばあ今下打ちしたしてねえ当たってね雨
ねりお
さっき
おお
喧嘩どうしましたどうしましたなんか足が
当たっ
て切れてました当たったんすか当たったっ
す蹴ってきたっすえ当てました当ててな
いっすこう言うんすよあやっちゃっていい
かいや
ちょっと今日でも新貸切なんでやっちゃっ
てくださいやっちゃっ
[音楽]
てはい楽しい時間もあっという間ですもう
新大阪ですね新大阪駅に着きますなんか
いろんなことして遊んでたら本当一瞬で
ついちゃったなあやばいもうついちゃう
ついちゃうマジでついちゃうえ貸し切りが
終わっちゃうもすぐさあもうもうつくもう
つくかあもうついちゃうもうつい
ちゃう夢の時間があああつい
てる新大阪行き着きましたああ楽しかった
さよなら俺の新幹線ありがとうございまし
たありがとうございましたありしあ
ありがとござありがとござまよろしくお
願いします願しますご乗車ありがとう
ございました新のC様に到着ですまた乗ろ